I'm Max.
I'm a Play Partner
Manager based in Berlin.
And what I do in
day-to-day interactions
is talk to app developers.
Could you just reset
the notes, please?
Talk to app developers about
their engagement strategies
across the whole device
ecosystem that is emerging.
And certainly, it's true
that, at the moment,
the hub of your interactions
with your customers
is the smartphone.
But what we're seeing
is a whole ecosystem
of smart and connected
devices coming to the fore,
and coming to the fore like
smart TVs, smart watches,
smart cars.
And they're creating new
avenues for user interactions.
The growth that we're seeing
in beacon deployments--
it's still in the
early stages, but it's
going to get bigger-- as well
as the growth of the Internet
of Things, will create
new opportunities for you
to interact with your users
in the physical world.
We've seen this slide before
just from Mateo's presentation.
But I think what it does, it
captures the point really well.
For you as developers,
it's a key challenge
to find strategies that take
advantage of the growing
connected device ecosystem.
And what we've seen
across categories of apps
is that frequent regular
interactions with your app
build loyal audiences
and increase
your chances of building
long-term customers
or long-term relationship
with your users.
So what I want to
do today is look
at how you can build
smart interaction
strategy for the multi-device
contextual world.
Oh, sorry.
I'm not in the spotlight.
And so in this
more complex world,
developers are finding new
answers to their questions.
So how do I personalize
and tailor interactions
with my users?
How do I take advantages of
these new device classes that
are emerging, and how do I build
a good interaction strategy
around it?
And how do I enable users
to interact with others
and the world around them?
So in the next 20
minutes or so, we'll
talk about how
Google can help you
with finding good answers
to those questions
and building a good strategy.
So let's start with
tailored interactions.
So this chart is
for the US only,
but it holds true for many
European countries as well.
So think about
this for a minute.
Next year, 60% of your app
users on their smartphone
will also be able to use
your app on their tablets.
I think that's quite
a staggering figure.
So what that means for your
services or for your apps,
for your products that depend
on logging in users to deliver
a personalized
content or services,
or to track the value of
your advertising channel
is that you basically
need to find a way
to provide your users
with a seamless login
experience across all the
devices that they're using.
And Google can
help you with that.
I want to introduce you to
Smart Lock for Passwords today.
It's a lightweight API
for Android and Chrome
that basically stores the login
information your users use
on web and in Android.
So it remembers whether they
use their email and password
or whether they might
have used Google sign-in
or Facebook to authenticate
themselves in your app.
And if they do that on the
web, Smart Lock for Passwords
will do the same on Android.
And the credentials
that the users enter
will sync seamlessly in
the background across all
the devices where the user is
logged in-- so across Android,
smartphones,
tablets, and Chrome.
So let's see what
it can actually do.
So if you have a
web presence and you
have a user that's authenticated
previously on the web
but now installs your
apps for the first time,
they won't see a login
screen or a prompt
to enter their
password, but they will
be signed in automatically.
So what we're seeing
with the launch partners
that we have out there
is that instantly they're
signing in 10% of their
audience on Android
just because they have
built up a big signed
in user base on web.
If multiple accounts
are registered,
Smart Lock for
Passwords will ask
the user, hey, do you want to
sign in with your Gmail account
or with your Hotmail account.
And so what that means for you
is that as users are moving
between platforms
or between devices,
they'll have no sign-in prompts.
You'll have no drop off.
And you'll have instant
personalization in your apps.
So you also will
encounter the situation
where a user will sign
up for the first time.
And when they create
an account in your app,
a prompt will appear and ask
the user to save their password.
Or if they want to
log in with Google,
it will remember that choice
and make that available
if they use your app on
a tablet or on the web.
And about 50% to 60% of
users say yes to that option
when prompted.
And we think we can do
even better with some UX
improvements in
that prompt flow.
And what we've seen is one of
the launch partners was Orbitz.
And they've seen a 5% increase
in the overall signed-in users
on Android just by having
that prompt appear.
So once you've
identified your users
on all the different
devices and made it easy
for them to
authenticate themselves
as they move between
devices-- I wanted
to talk a little bit about
notifications as a key user
interaction strategy
and the tools
that we have available to help.
So we've seen that notifications
are a key tool to make sure
that users keep coming back.
But to really have a material
impact on engagement,
you need to ask yourself a
couple of important questions
to formulate your
notification strategy.
So you need to have
a key objective.
So what this developer
is doing ShareTheMeal,
where the key objective
is to solicit a donation.
So when they send
you a notification,
they want you to go
into the app and donate.
And they're also
trying to figure out
the context of the
notification and the timing.
So here the context is
you get a notification
at breakfast, lunch, or dinner.
And then the timing would
be, or the frequency
would be once a week, once
a month, once a day even.
And then what you also
need to figure out,
once you have those
questions answered,
is to say, how
can I target users
that fall into these different
groups for notifications.
And also you need to think
about what technical resources
you want to invest to actually
implement your notification
strategy.
And Google Cloud Messaging is
a free notification service
from Google that
actually helps you
deliver your world-class
notification strategies.
So it's fit for all use cases.
You can use it to send messages
to do background syncing,
to implement
messaging, use cases.
You can enable cross-device
platform messaging.
So if someone likes
your photo somewhere,
you get a notification
on all your devices.
The value is that it's built
on Google infrastructure.
And it's reliable under
high message loads.
So you don't have to worry
about not reaching your users
when it's critical.
It also keeps power
consumption down,
which is great because
your app doesn't
have to pull your servers.
And it basically reduces
engineering complexity for you
as you're implementing
your strategy.
And the great
thing is it's free.
And it has any features
that are out of betas,
don't have any caps or
restrictions on usage.
One key feature I want
to highlight-- oh, it's
a little logo missing.
So this is the cloud
messaging logo here.
One feature that's new and that
was a highly asked-for feature
is the topic messaging.
Oh, there it is.
So what you can do is you
can assign users to topics.
So first what you do is
you create a topic list.
Say, call it app marketing.
And then you can automatically
assign users to that list.
So you have a list of devices
that subscribe to that topic.
Or you can actively
ask users to sign in,
so you can have a
little question,
are you an app
marketing manager,
or something like that.
And then you can send a message
to Google simply saying,
there's a new open beta
on topic messaging,
and send it to the
topic app marketing.
And you don't have to worry
about all your subscription
management anymore
because all of that
is taken care of by Google.
And the great
thing about that is
that you have a fast
and efficient way
to implement subscriptions.
At the moment, this
is still in beta.
So there's a cap of 1
million subscribers per app.
So we've covered the
tailored interaction piece.
Now we're going to move on to
how to extend your interaction
strategies to other devices.
So starting with
phones and tablets
and going to TVs and wearables
and cars, Android is expanding.
Android and Play provide
you with a platform.
But these platforms
really come to life
and create value for
users with the apps
that you as developers build.
So now this is still
a very new field.
So it's a great time
to think about how
you can tailor your interaction
strategies to these new devices
and platforms.
So I'm really, and we're
all really excited to see
what you come up with.
Talking about wear, there are
really three use cases that,
in order of the integration
work and complexity, that you
can do to drive users
of the wear platform
and of our smart watches
back into your app
and to interact with them.
So notifications is great
because mostly notifications
already worked out of the box.
If you have optimized your
notifications for Android,
then they already work on wear.
If you've enhanced
your notifications
with action buttons,
then those actions
automatically work on wear.
And there's great
wear-specific enhancements
that you can do like stacks,
pages, and voice replies.
Watch faces are also
great because they
give you or your brand or your
app a really prominence base
on the wrist of the user and on
the most glanced at real estate
on their very personal device.
So what you can do is you
can push relevant updates
from your app into the
watch face which is great.
And then on the most complex
spectrum you have apps.
So you can build these apps.
And they run on the wear device.
And they can do almost anything
that a smartphone app can do.
So they are equipped-- they
can use the sensors on the wear
device.
And we'll go a little
bit into the use cases.
So enabling great
wear experiences,
we haven't stopped innovating
as we launched wear last year.
We've actually made
great improvements.
So one of the key things
I want to highlight
is the Always On functionality.
So basically, it
allows your app to be
on in the foreground
drawing very little energy
and updating at
longer intervals--
so maybe every 10 seconds.
And so for example, running
apps can show the distance
that you've traveled.
Or it can show you
your boarding gate
as you walk into the airport
without using too much energy
and drawing down the
power of the wearable.
And another thing that we've
launched is the watch face.
So it's interactive watch faces.
So basically, you
can and tap on custom
designed watch faces to show
other content or more relevant
content.
So you can tap on a watch face
and tap the calendar button
and see your agenda for
the day without actually
going into the app.
So we've also launched
other upgrades.
So for example,
we're allowing apps
to use Wi-Fi when you're
away from the phone.
That's great.
You can use the onboard GPS.
So that's great
for running apps.
And you can access,
actually, the map's API.
And you can have great mapping
experience on the wear device.
And we also have
iOS support now.
So here's some great examples.
One is the guardian which--
it's taking long time to load.
The guardian notifies
you of the latest news
directly on your watch.
So if you're actually interested
in that piece of news,
you can make a note of it
and have it saved later
for reading on your phone.
City mapper has a
great use case where
it shows you how to get from
A to B in most major cities.
And with Always
On, it saves energy
while you're commuting
around London.
And American Airlines
has a great use case
where all your
flight information
is available on your
wrist which is great
if you don't want to keep
getting out your smartphone
because you forgot what
seat you're sitting in,
and you're also
carrying some luggage.
WhatsApp is really great because
they've enhanced their wear app
so that you sometimes
don't even have
to open your phone anymore.
You can reply right
from your wrist.
And then obviously, fitness.
I was talking about that before.
You can have the Always
On mode and always see
as you're running
how far you've run
and how much time
you've spent running.
And then for travel--
that should say music.
Spotify lets you seamlessly
browse your playlist.
So if you're at
home and you've got
your phone plugged on--
you're walking around--
you can press play.
And you can control your music
from the comfort of your couch
without having to get up
and getting your phone.
I'm going to talk a little
bit about our TV experiences
as well.
So we've got Google
Cast and Android TV.
Firstly, Cast is
a technology that
lets you cast wirelessly from
your favorite entertainment
apps on phone, tablet,
or websites on a computer
to your TV or speakers.
So we have a really
strong presence with Cast.
We've sold over 17
million devices globally.
And you can buy Cast in 26
countries from 35,000 stores.
And this is a really
mobile platform,
so it aligns well
with consumer trends.
And what we're
seeing is that we're
seeing a 60% year-on-year
growth of per device usage.
And already, 22,000
apps support Cast.
Android TV is designed
for a different use case.
It's more for a, call
it lean-back experience.
So you're just
sitting on your sofa.
And you don't already know
what you want to watch.
But you just want to
switch on your smart TV.
And our goal there is
to create an experience
where you basically discover
new media content while you're
sitting in your living room.
Some of the partners
that we have
are TV vendors, such as
Sony, Philips, and Grundig.
And we're also working with
over the top boxes and gaming
consoles.
So we've got Nexus
devices, NVIDIA, Huawei,
and Razor devices out
there because it's also
a great gaming platform.
So for Cast, how it
works technically,
is that you've got Cast
for audio and video.
You've also got games
for Google Cast.
So you can build
great HTML5 games.
And you can in other use cases
to extend your apps or your app
user experience to
a second screen.
So you can have a dual
screen experience.
With Android TV and the lean
back libraries that we have,
we are asking you to
create a catalog browser
and to provide a card view and
detailed background playing
cards.
So if someone's watching
a program in your app
and switches out of
your app, it still
keeps playing in the background.
What's really
important on Android TV
is that you make it easy for
users to discover your content.
So we advise that you make your
content searchable, your app
searchable and also to enable
searching while the user is
inside your app which
is very important
as well to surface
the right content.
I also want to talk about
Android Auto a little bit.
We're having a slow
start with Android Auto.
But we're already live
with VW, Seat, and Skoda,
and an Audi is coming soon.
Also GM brands such as Voxel
is announced for early 2016.
And in Europe, you can buy
pioneer aftermarket upgrades
for Android Auto, or users
can buy aftermarket upgrades.
And we know that
other manufacturers--
so we've signed up
28 manufacturers--
are coming soon to also offer
Android Auto experiences.
So if you have apps
in the messaging space
or in the music space,
now is a really great time
to build a footprint there.
I also want to quickly
mention Cardboard.
What it does is it basically
makes it easy for developers
to build virtual
reality experiences
into their mobile apps by
offering an open source
toolkit that takes care of
a lot of common VR tasks
that you're faced with
such as dealing with lens
distortion correction
and head tracking.
So that's a great way to
extend the user interactions
with your apps to different
platforms and emerging devices.
Lastly, I want to
talk a little bit
about how your apps can interact
with the world around them
and how users can interact
with other users around them.
So let's talk a little bit about
the Nearby Proximity API first.
This is a new technology
that was recently
released by Google
that basically allows
you to build beautiful
experiences that
lets your users discover each
other when they're close by
or to discover beacons
when their close by.
So there are two
components-- nearby messages.
So that means devices that
are close by can exchange
messages easily such as editing
something, maybe a whiteboard
in a room, or forming a
group of voting on something
or broadcasting resources.
And there's also
nearby connections
which lets devices on the same
network discover each other.
And then it's used in
multiplayer gaming.
And the cool thing about
the Nearby Proximity API
is that it's available
for iOS, Android,
and also for interacting
with beacon devices.
And it doesn't require you
to sign in your users which
is great as well.
And it also lets you concentrate
on the actual use cases
that you want to implement,
and Google handles the rest.
So we communicate with other
devices via Bluetooth, Wi-Fi,
and also by inaudible
sounds that are picked up
by devices but not humans.
What we've seen-- we've got
some really nice showcase
implementations.
So we have edjing, which
has a cool new case
for playlist voting.
So the DJ publishes
their playlists,
and the listeners
can vote on what song
they want to hear next.
We have Pocket Casts, where
basically two people or more
can publish the podcasts
that they're subscribed to.
And then you can
pick out podcasts
that might be interesting to you
and subscribe to them as well.
And Trello shares project
boards, basically,
that are nearby, so
you can subscribe
to do a project board
from someone who's,
for example, in this room.
So that's really
a great technology
to interact with people and
other people, other users that
are in your apps and get them to
engage more with your product.
I also want to mention beacons.
So basically, rather
poetically, think
of beacons as
lighthouses that are
attached to physical objects
or somewhere in the room.
And they provide a precise
location and contextual cues
to apps that want to use them.
So for example, we could
label a bus stop with beacons.
So your phone knows
to show you the times
when the next bus arrives
or to have the ticket ready.
Or we can have a museum that has
a beacon attached to an exhibit
and provide additional
information or background
information to an exhibit.
The way that Google helps you
with this kind of interaction
is we have the Google
beacon platform.
And it's comprised,
basically, of three parts.
You've got the
low-cost beacon devices
that have to comply with
our hardware specifications
so that we know that they
will work with our APIs.
We have the Eddystone format
that is the beacon format
that-- it's an open source
format made by Google
that basically defines
three payloads.
You can have a device identifier
which can provide context
to your app so
that you can engage
with them so you can build
interactive experiences on top
of them.
The Eddystone beacons can
broadcast compressed URLs.
So you can launch
experiences right--
so you can launch a deep
link right into the app
where it matters.
And they also broadcast
telemetry data.
So it will tell
you the temperature
in the beacon, whether it's
moving, things like that.
So you can build
experiences around that.
And then we also have
the proximity beacon API
which allows you to
register fleets of beacons
and manage them remotely
so that you don't have
to go to every beacon
that you have installed
and make sure that
they're still running
and have enough battery left.
The last thing I
want to get into
is provide a look at the
future at what's out there,
what we're working on.
And that's Brillo and Weave.
We're trying to take the
next steps after beacons
and really enable the
Internet of Things.
So Brillo is really
the Android platform
for your connected devices.
So they're basically
our standards
so that they're easy
to set up and they
talk to each other
the way they should.
And Brillo, think of it as
basically the operating system
of the Internet of Things.
Weave is the Internet of
Things protocol on top of that.
It provides seamless and
secure communications
between your
devices, so not just
between your smartphone and
an Internet of Things device
but also between
devices themselves.
And it's also integrated
into Google Play
so that right from
the start Android
app developers can start
building beautiful applications
on top of that.
And it will make sure that all
the devices are interoperable.
And there's a
certification program
and in place to make sure that
all the standards are kept.
That brings me to the end.
So thank you very much
for your interest.
I hope the path that I wanted
to take you on was clear.
So we have the tailored
interactions for the platforms
that are really
well-established now
and are core to your business.
Then we have the emerging
platforms, like wear
and smart TVs and
Chromecasts and cardboard,
and that are also
important to think about
to really make sure
you're reaching your users
where it matters.
And then going beyond that, the
connected world, the beacons,
and the Internet of Things where
it's really important to start
thinking about how you're
going to reach your users there
and how to make sure they
come back into your app.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]